All right. I'm here at Mozilla with Steve Fink, who has worked on regular expressions
and languages and parsing, just-in-time transformation and optimizations for Mozilla
and other opensource projects.
I was wondering are there any times where you've used regular expressions in the real world?
[Steve Fink:] Yeah. Just yesterday I was at the grocery store, and I could not find the sugar shelf.
Sorry, that was a dream. Let's cancel that.
So we have been having a problem recently on the Firefox browser
where we get periodic stalls.
Often this is some event that happened--
a key press, a timer fires off, something like that.
We take 100 milleseconds or something to service it.
I pulled out my standard tools, which are Perl, regular expressions,
and I wrote a little script.
It's like one regular expression to identify that this is a class declaration
and another one to find what an error is from,
another one to find a run method, which has to exist on all these,
which just gives me a good place to stick my code in. And it kind of worked.
That's one example where I've done this. I tend to do this fairly often. >>Excellent.